hello and welcome to this video playing
poison porn is a pest now right they see
that the top guys play the Italian game
and then they follow suit okay i know
that i know that a 5 is probably even a
bit better but didn't feel ready for it
at the moment here channel for something
that i know a little bit better okay
since six this is what i've played for
most of my be 45 chest korea and the
other line that I've made a video on I
only recently studied and don't feel so
yeah well well prepared oh listen hmm
hmm John Bishop f4 that looks damned
uncomfortable what the beep should okay
probably have to make b5 work otherwise
this this this looks really bad and so
where it's going to be five okay the 56
looks wrong entirely wrong actually
probably I should have played the other
line that's what I get for playing what
I supposedly should know but at the end
it turns out I know nothing I don't know
what did her to Rome don't quite know
okay well it still seems like a fairly
healthy position I think
still a bum decently centralized here is
e 5 coming I don't know now this one ok
I want them to just take it like that
yeah so I can also check 1c5 first
mm or queen to see seven maybe Quintus
is seven here and throw in this this one
I would like to play and something other
than that but I have to borrow queen bee
six
yeah that's a piece for piece I think
white resigns ok so now SML screw this
up right in the opening chess is the
absolutely normal way to play it there's
this I probably I forgot to play b5 here
right I should play beehive not castles
maybe this is not like super awful but
it's far more precise to to play on to
play this first or queen c7 first this
is also making quite some sense so that
now I have this idea even though this is
in the position okay I can take here
right okay I'll probably catch this okay
and this is this wasn't so precise and
now I have to move the Queen again yeah
it's not awful but it's it's not just
not precise yeah then I was happy about
I think I'd looked quite quite decent no
okay 95 is giving me the game he has so
many normal moves like this for example
trying to place you for this should be
equal I think I pieces some rather okay
nothing it's nothing off let's say about
blacks position White has this good
center pawn the computer gives equal I
think maybe maybe why this is a bit more
comfortable but it's not it's not a lot
and this was yeah just dropping this
piece okay thanks for watching